شكرا لك طاهر مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون
معكم في تغطيتنا للتطورات في السودان حيث
اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن
تواصل الضغط من اجل تمديد وقف اطلاق النار
في السودان اضافت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها
تنسق مع شركاء اقليميين ودوليين للمساعده
في تشكيل لجنه للاشراف على المفاوضات
مشيره الى انها تسعى لمساعده الفصائل
المتحاربه لتحديد مسار لوقف دائم للاعمال
العدائيه وذلك بعد اتصال مع القاده
العسكريين والمدنيين
يعني لا مويه لامور لاموات ذات الناس
تستعمله والحجه
ورافعين ارتفاع الجنون
بم
من خلق الهدنه
الطرف الاخر
تبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بات كتبادل اطلاق النار جزء من يوميات
الحرب الدائره رحاها في شوارع الخرطوم
هدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ما انطلقت حتى
بدات البيانات بالصدور تاره من الجيش الذي
قال انه رصد استمرار التحركات العسكريه
لقوات الدعم داخل وخارج العاصمه ومحاوله
السيطره على مواقع وتقييد تحركات
المواطنين بالاضافه الى حركه كثيفه
بمجموعات متفاوته نحو مصفاه الجيل للسيطره
عليها وخلق ازمه في امدادات الوقود بكامل
البلاد
قوه الدعم السريع من خلال حسابها على
تويتر شجبت انتهاك الجيش الهدنه متهمه
اياه بالقيام بالقصف العشوائي الامر الذي
يعرض حياه المدنيين للخطر هذا الشد والجذب
تزامن مع امال الجهات الدوليه في نجاح
الهدنه حيث حث مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل من خلال
حسابه في تويتر الطرفين على الالتزام حتى
يتم التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه المدنيين
اوعد الابرياء اما واشنطن حسب وزير
خارجيتها انتوني بلينكن فهي تعمل مع
شركائها لتشكيل لجنه تتفاوض على وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار في السودان
البرهان وداكلو حليفا الامس عدوا اليوم
اللذان تسبب صراعهما على السلطه حتى الان
في قتل اكثر من
459 شخصا حسب الصحه العالميه التي قدرت ان
اعداد الضحايا اكثر من هذا الرقم بكثير اذ
لم يتم احصاء القتلى في مناطق كثيره بسبب
القصف الكثيف العربيه
هذا ما نشد عدد من المواطنين في السودان
عبر كاميرا العربيه جميع الاطراف في
السودان لوقف القتال وتامين حاجيات
المواطنين وتامين المحلات التجاريه التي
تعرضت للنهب والسلب خلال الاشتباكات
نحن ما حراميه نحن سودانيين
يدك على حق غيرك بانه الناس الشعب
السوداني تعب لانه حاصل غلاء في الوطن
السودان في غلاء شديد لا في مويه لا في
كهرباء الناس متجهه لبخاع السودان نسبه
لضيق المعيشه في البلد وعدم توفر الامان
ما شايف شرطي واحد في الشارع لو نزلت
الشرطه امنتوا المواطنين نزلتوا البنزين
نزلته كل الناس حترتاح
نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط ونتكلم
عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني محترم لا
يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق غيره نتكلم
عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت في المحنه
دي لا لا للحرب
منا الحاج يوسف
وكافوري
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اجلت الامم المتحده المئات من
موظفيها العاملين في السودان مع عائلاتهم
واوضح مراسل العربيه في السودان ان عمليه
الاجلاء تمت عبر ميناء بورسودان
اكد المبعوث الخاص للامم المتحده الى
السودان فولكربرت ان مهمه اجلاء المئات من
موظفي الامم المتحده من السودان كانت مهمه
صعبه
العمليه الصعبه احد الوقت اكثر مما كان
مخطط لها ولكن العمليه
العمليه تمت ومشيت بسلام والمهم بالنسبه
اننا
جئنا مع هذه القافله من الخاتون لبورت
السودان
وانه حاليا
الاطفال والعائلات على السفينه الفرنسيه
قالت الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للعربيه ان عمليه اجلاء الرعايه معقده بعض
الشيء وكان من المفترض ان تتم بعد الحصول
على ضمانات لاجلاء نحو 500 شخص من السودان
انها عمليه معقده ميدانيا ودبلوماسيا
لانها جرت فيما يتواصل القتال في السودان
كان يجب القيام بسلسله اتصالات تسمح
باعطاءنا ضمانات امنيه لاجلاء حوالي 500
شخص من السودان كما هو معلوم تمكننا من
اجلاء رعايانا والطاقم الدبلوماسي وايضا
اجلين عددا كبيرا جدا من الرعايا الاجانب
في السودان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتهم السودانيون سائقين حافلات بزياده
اسعار تذاكر السفر من الخرطوم الى ولايات
اكثر امانا الامر الذي اثار غضب واستيالها
واعتبر الكثير من السودانيين الامر
استغلالا واضحا من قبل السائقين لكسب
المال رغم الظروف الصعبه التي تمر بها
البلاد بسبب المعارك المندلعه في مدنها
بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
استغلال ذاته بشر من اصحاب الاوساط
ويعني التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب سعر
وبعد باتر بيسعد عن الصباح 250 الليله
350 اسوان
القاهره ب 400 الف
تعاني مشارح الخرطوم من ضعف السعه
الاستيعابيه بعد ان ظلت الاف جثامين مكدسه
فيها لاكثر من ثلاثه اعوام كما وتهدد
مخلفات الحرب من اكوام قمامه
متفشيه في الشوارع من ازمتين صحيه وبيئيه
قد تتفشى اذا ما عالجت الدوله جمله
ازماتها عاجلا
[موسيقى]
ملقون على جنبات الشوارع السودان منكبون
على ظهورهم او بطونهم لا فرق
هذا احد تقاطعات حي الحلفايه يلفظ جثه
مرميه على الاطراف
لايام وما زالت اجسادهم تربك الطرقات
يمشون بجانبها متجاهلين ان انفاسها انقطعت
وبل من القصف يعرقل سبل نقل رفاتهم فالحي
منهم لا يجرؤ على الذهاب بجثامينهم الى
المشرحه لتكدوسها وايضا خشيه ان ترضيه
رصاصه ظلت طريقها اليه فلا هدنه تفي
بالحياه
[موسيقى]
من هنا تنبعث رائحه موت اخر تفوح منه ازمه
صحيه وبيئيه ففي مستشفى الساحه مثلا يتجمع
الجرح من قوه الدعم السريع لكن الكادر
الطبي يعجز عن معالجه الاعداد المتزايده
من الاصابات استمرار نزف احدهم يشي بزياده
عدد القتلى وتضاف اليه عباره كارثيه لا
متسعه لمزيد من الجثث في مشارح الخرطوم
التي تكابد اعدادهم لثلاث سنوات
فمنها جثث تعفنت واخرى تحللت اما عن
رائحتها فحدث ولا حرج
مخلفات الحرب تهدد السودان وتضعه في
تحديات معقده فهناك نفايات بالاكوام
تتكاثر فيها فرص انتشار الامراض المعديه
والجرثوميه لتكاثر الحشرات والذباب حولها
وانبعاث الروائح الكريهه هي المصائب هكذا
لا تاتي فرادى على السودان حرب دروس محمله
بازمتين صحيه وبيئيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الان خبر عاجل متعلق
بالرئيس
السوداني السابق عمر البشير أحمد هارون
وهو المسؤول في نظام البشير السابق يقول
انه غادر سجن كوبر مع اخرين من قيادات
نظام البشير الذين كانوا معتقلين في سجن
كوبر وبانهم الان في جهه امنه بعد تامين
انفسهم
طيب نعود الان الى متابعه جديده التطورات
والوضع الصحي كذلك بالاساس المثير للقلق
في السودان معنا من الخرطوم اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني
استاذ اسامه اهلا بك معنا ابدا معك من
مساله الجثث الملقاه على قارعه الطريق في
الخرطوم اضافه الى مشكله الجثث المتكدسه
اصلا في المشارح في السودان الى اي حد هذه
المواجهه العسكريه تزيد من هذه الازمه
بالطبع يعني حتى رغم الهدنه المعلنه اللي
هي مطبقه جزئيا الى انه المعاناه
الانسانيه بتزيد بشكل مخيف سواء كانت على
مستوى الجثث الملقاه على قارعه الطريق وما
يخلف من اضرار بيئيه اضافه للناس الجرحى
والمرضى في المستشفيات وعدم قدره
المستشفيات على الطلبه المتزايد من المرضى
والمصابين يضاف للفقره الموجود في
المستشفيات
وعدم وجود ابسط المستلزمات المطلوبه
قطعه الكهربائيه والمياه
هي ازمه كبيره جدا فضلا عن المرض العاديين
بيستعملوا ادويه مستمره الامراض المزمنه
الصيدليات مغلقه الوضع الصحي اصبح اكبر من
الكارثه
ولذلك نحن لا نفك نناشد في كل مناسبه
نناشد طرفي النزاع
لضروره
اعلان
هدنهن واضحه جدا ومسارات امنه بتمكين
الفرق الطبيه ولتمكين الدعم اللوجستي
والدعم بالادويه والمعينات ان تصل
المستشفيات اضافه
ليتمكن حتى
استاذ اسامه عذرا على المقاطعه
المشارح اصلا الجثث فيها والجثمين فيها
اقصد مكدسه اصلا هناك مشكله سعه استيعابيه
في المشاريح السودانيه في الخرطوم فهل
المسارات الامنه او الهدنه الصلبه يعني
يعني ما نفعها اذا كانت هناك اصلا مشكله
في السعه الاستيعابيه في المشارح
نعم نعم هو في الدايما الجثث المقدسه في
المشارح دي يا اما مثلا ما بيكون مستدلين
على هويه اصحابه او مثلا ما مستدلين على
هويه شخص يتصلوا عشان يجي يستلم الجثمان
مثلا ويدفنوا او بيكونوا يتلاقوا بشكل
عربي يعني مشكله كبيره جدا ما هي واحده من
المشاكل اذا تم
يعني السماح بسط الامن في هذه المناطق
بوسع الهلال الاحمر ليس بالمفرده ولكن
بوسع الهلال الاحمر ان يساهم في علاج هذه
المشكله لانه عندنا الهلال عنده اطقم
مدربه تدريب عالي في
انتشال الجثث والتحقق منها
وايصال للجهه بتاعتها على اساس تدفنه نحن
عندنا تجربه حيه حصلت امس او اول امس او
الصبح امس اللي هي عندنا في ولايه جنوب
دارفور في نيالا مدينه نيالا عندنا اطق م
المتطوعين المتخصصين في نقل
الجثثوا سبعه جثث في منطقه يسيطر عليها
الجيش السوداني
وهذه الجثث تتباع
[موسيقى]
للجهال للجانب الاخر الدعم السريع
ايوه حصل ايه
كليه الهلال الاحمر جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السوداني بحكم ثقه الطرفين فيها انا مؤسسه
محايده
بالاسعاف الطبي للدعم السرير والاسعاف
الطبي للقوات المسلحه وتم الاتفاق على
اساس انه الهلال الاحمر يجمع الجثث
بالطريقه العلميه حتى المطوعين يرتدوا
يعني زي خاص لحمايته من اي تلوث وتم تسليم
هذه الجثث في حضور مندوبين السلاح الطبي
للدعم السريع الطبي هل هذه نقطه مهمه
استاذ اسامه يعني تجربه نيالا هذه هل يمكن
التاسيس عليها في الخرطوم ايضا لان هناك
يعني مشاهد مؤلمه لجثث
بقيه ملقاه في الشوارع يعني لايام
حتى لو التجربه بتاعت مياه التجربه محدوده
لكن يمكن التاسيس على طالما في فرق بتؤدي
هذه المهام
واسف انه الاتيان المتخصصه في نقل الجثث
تتمكن من اداء دولها بدون اي تحديد امني
لها دي المساله الاساسيه يعني شوف القصه
بتاعه الجثث القصص بتاعه تكدس المستشفيات
انها تشتغل ابدا القصه بتاعت انه
المستشفيات فيها نقص كبير جدا في الكادر
الطبي اذا اذا تاملت مس امنه حتى الكوادر
الطبيه في المستشفيات الذين لم يتمكنوا من
الحضور الى المستشفيات منذ يوم السبت قبل
الماضي مع اندلاع النزاع حيقدروا يجيوا
المستشفى مع ضمانات امنيه والهلال الاحمر
نفسه حيتلقى الدعم في دعم كبير جدا الهلال
الاحمر من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
والاتحاد جمعيات الصليب والهلال الاحمر
حتى من مؤسسات خارج منظومه الهلال الاحمر
والصليب الاحمر يعني
الضمانات الامنيه دي مساله مهمه جدا مش
اللي للقضاء على الكارثه لكن للحد من
الاثار
دي دي مساله مهمه جدا جدا
شغال بجوز كبير جدا من طاقته الممكن
يستخدمها بس ما بقدر يستخدم
الطاقه اللي احنا ذكرناها يعني اسامه ابو
بكر المسؤول العلمي الهلالي الاحمر
السوداني شكرا جزيلا لك لحديثك الينا
مباشره من الخرطوم
مساجين مدينه الامل
تم اطلاق سراحهم الان
مدينه الامل
من امام
الجسم مدينه العمل
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدين اول مزيد من الاخبار العاجله
والتفاصيل ترد فيما يتعلق بمساله خروج
القيادات من نظام البشير من سجن كوبر
وحديثهم عن اللجوء الى منطقه امنه لتامين
انفسهم احمد هارون المسؤول بنظام البشير
يقول انهم مسؤولون للمثول امام القضاء في
اي وقت ويضيف الان
بان بانهم مكثوا في سجن كوبر تحت حراسه
محدوده طبعا هو يشير هنا الى انعدام
الامان اذا في ظل الاقتتال الدائر بين
الجيش والدعم السريع وهو يعلن اذن
الانتقال برفقه قيادات من نظام البشير
ايضا الى منطقه اكثر امانا نعرف اكثر من
مراسلنا من الخرطوم سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك
معنا سالم المزيد من المعلومات لو سمحت عن
موضوع انتقال قيادات نظام البشير من سجن
كوبر الى منطقه اكثر امانا
الساده المشاهدين طبعا هذا الموضوع تم
طوله قبل ايام تقريبا من الان موضوع
سالم
نعم نعم صوتك تقطع نعم ذكرت انه موضوع
اعلان انتقال قيادات البشريه كان منذ ايام
هو لم يكن منذ ايام تم تداوله على التواصل
الاجتماعي لكن جاء النفي بعد ذلك
المصادر كثيره اكدت انهم لم يخرجوا انهم
متواجدون وانما تم اطلاق
هذا اليوم بالتاكيد لتلك الاشاعه التي
صدرت في ذلك اليوم خروج
المساجين وانهم خرجوا حتى هم يقومون
بحمايتيهم بحسب نص الخبر بمن فيهم الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير صحيح
نعم الان هم لم يتحدثون الذي تحدث الان هو
احمد هارون
بالمؤتمر الوطني وكان
مسؤولا الى سقوط النظام عن هذا الحزب
باكمله بعد البكل تاكيد مباشره
هذا احمد هارون كان هنالك مجموعه من التهم
وجهت اليه قبل
قبل ان تاتي هذه الاشتباكات اي بعده سقوط
نظام البشير مباشره
والغريب انه كان بعيدا كل البعد حتى عن
المحاكمات التي
وضحت في وسائل الاعلام التي كانت منقوله
لاعضاء نظام البشير
لديه تهم كذلك في ما يتعلق بدرس وكان
وزيرا للداخليه وكان واليا لعده من
الولايات تقلد هذه المناصب في عهد البشير
لكن
بالنسبه لتاكيد انهم كلهم خرجوا هذا الامر
يحتاج الى مزيد من التدقيق والتمحيص لان
الذي تحدث الان احمد هارون ولكن يمكن ان
يفهم من كلامه انهم جميعا خارج السجن
وانهم يؤمنون انفسهم بما فيهم الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير نعم هذا ما اردت
الاشاره اليه لاننا نعرف انه عمر البشير
كان مسجون في سجن كوبر وبالتالي عندما يتم
اخراج القيادات وتامينها في المنطقه اكثر
امانا يعني يفهم من هذا انه اكيد من بينهم
رئيس السابق عمر البشير ايضا جرى نقله الى
مكان امن
نعم لكن حديث ايضا احمد هارون عن انهم
تحدث على انهم يفرقون تماما بين السلطه
الانقلابيه واجهزه الدوله الوطنيه في
مقدمتها القوات المسلحه التي تقاتله بقوه
وشرف وتحدث على دعوتهم لابناء الشعب
السوداني للاكتفاء حول القوات المسلحه
والمساندتها واقتراح المبادرات التي تستند
دورها الوطني ايضا اكد انهم كقيادات
للانقاذ في سجن كوبر تحت النيران لمده
تسعه ايام ونتشارك مع السجناء ظروف امنيه
استثنائيه هذا بحسب وصفه ايضا قال واجهنا
خلال الاشتباكات الحاليه انعدام مقومات
الحياه من قطاع تام للمياه والكهرباء
والرعايه الصحيه
وانه توفي جراء الاشتبادات العديد من
النزلاء وجرح هارون بسبب هذه الاشتباكات
التي كانت دائره هذا سالم عذرا على
المقاطعه هل يفهم من هذا انه سلطات الجيش
هي التي قامت بتامين نقل القيادات نظام
البشير بما فيهم البشير ام هو هكذا يعلن
انهم فروا من السجن
نعم لكن هو بكل الاحوال الان المعلومه
اصبحت متاحه الان للجيش السوداني وهاهم
النزلاء نفسهم هم اكدوا بانهم خارج السجن
فالان ربما يصدر موقف من الجيش تجاه هذا
الامر ببيان واضح لكن يفهم من هذا الامر
ايضا
انه ما دام هناك جرحى في جراء الاشتباكات
داخل السجن انه كانت هنالك اشتباكات في
محيط سجن كوبر او بالقرب منه مادام هنالك
جرحى لان هذا الخبر قد تناولناه هنا في
قناه العربيه والحدث
تم نفي هذا الخبر تماما فهذا انه كان صحيح
انه كان هناك اشتباكات حول محيط سجن كهر
ودليل هذا الحديث الذي ذكره بوجود جرحى
وكذا
هنالك ايضا من نزلاء انا اسال لانه احمد
هارون يا سالم
القيادي في نظام البشير يقول انه السلطات
السجن قامت بنقلهم الى مكان اكثر امانا
ما دامت هي التي قامت بنقلهم ولمكان اكثر
امانا اذا
المسلحه على علم في هذا الامر والمعلم هنا
ايضا ان السودانيه هي من تديرها
التي تقوم على حراسته ايضا كانت هنالك في
الايام الماضيه حديث يدور عن
مواضيع كثيره متعلقه بنظام السابق ليس
خروج السجناء من كوبر وحده هو الامر
الوحيد المتعلق بالنظام السابق هناك امور
اخرى تم تداولها حدثته عن الدفاع الشعبي
وعودته والحديث عنه هي قوه كانت تتبع
للنظام السابق او نظام الحركه الاسلاميه
هنالك ايضا الحديث عن
المواضيع المتعلقه بهذا الامر وتم تداولها
ايضا مثل حقيقه تصريحات القيادي في نظام
البشير يعني فيها اشارات مختلطه يعني من
جهه اداره سجن كوبر اجلت القيادات ومن جهه
اخرى يقول انه هذه القيادات جاهزه للمثول
امام القضاء في ايه لحظه
انتظار تبيان الموقف حقيقه يعني اذا كان
يعني هم الان تحت اشراف الجيش تحت اشراف
السلطات نحن في انتظار المزيد من التفاصيل
سالم في الحديث عن انهم يفرقون بين السلطه
الانقلابيه واجهزه الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها القوات المسلحه التي
تقالبيه هو يقصد
يقصد قوات الدعم السريع في انها تسعى
للانقلاب على القوات المسلحه
سالم اعذرني مع بهذا القدر على ان نعود
اليك اتباع ان تكون جماعه المزيد من
المعلومات لموافاتنا بها طبعا اولا باول
نعود اليك حاله توافر المزيد من المعطيات
حول هذا التطور اللافت شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الان سالم
قال مسؤولون بالامم المتحده اين المنظمه
تضع خططا لاستقبال مئات الالاف من الذين
يتدفقون عبر الحدود السودانيه هربا من
العنف ومع تواصل النزاع في السودان يستمر
خروج الالاف من البلاد عبر عده مسارات
ووسط ظروف صعبه
ريق للخروج من السودان الاف الاشخاص من
عشرات الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر
الامان وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما
تسنى لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او
جوا في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم اللاجئ جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤق ته
لمن غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي
او بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
العربيه
مشاهدينا عوده لموضوع مغادره البشير
والقيادات من نظامه من سجن كوبر نتابع هذا
التسجيل الصوتي لاحمد هارون المسؤول في
نظام البشير وماذا قال
2019 بما في ذلك حبسنا كرهائن لديها طلبا
لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه ودوليه ثبت
الان انها العدو الاول للشعب السوداني
وللسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه فهي من
تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
[موسيقى]
تحت تقاطع نيران المعرفه الدائره الان
لمده تسعه ايام
نتشارك وبرقيه نزلاء السين وسجانيه تلك
الظروف الامنيه الاستثنائيه
وانعدام مقومات الحياه من انقطاع تام
للمياه والكهرباء والطعام والرعايه الصحيه
حتى للجرحى من جراء تساقط النيران وسط قوه
السجون والنزلاء والتي توفى من جرائها
العديد منهم وجرح عدد اخر
حتى خلى تماما من نزلائه وسيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره
من قاده وضباط وافراد السنين وبناء على
طلب القوه المتبقيه من قوه السجون تحركنا
لموقع اخر خارج السي
تحت حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه على امل ان تتحصل سلطات السجون على
امر القضاء بالافراج عنا حسب افادتها خلال
ذلك اليوم لنواجه مع جماهير شعبنا لا تزور
فيه وتحدياته والقيام معه بذات الواجبات
الوطني فلم تعد هناك سيون قائمه ولا مقار
لمباشره اجهزه ووكالات انفاذ القانون
لمهامها
وهكذا في الانقياده ضريبتها والتزاماتها
ونفخر ونحمد الله كثيرا على تشربنا تماما
لقيم موروثات شعبنا التي يعبر عنها بالمثل
السمعه ولا طوله العمر
واذا عدم صدور الامر القضائي المستحق
قانونا لاسباب غير قانونيه
نفضي عنها لاحقا وفي ظل تسارع وتتابع
الاحداث وازدياد حته الاشتباكات وتعاظم
النذر والمخاطر من حولنا وفي ظل انشغال
السلطات الاخرى بمهامها في اداره المعركه
الوطنيه الان القائمه فقد اتخذنا قرارنا
الخاص بنا بان نتحمل المسؤوليتنا في حمايه
انفسنا بانفسنا
وجاهزون للوصول امام السلطه القضائيه متى
ما تمكنت من القيام بمهامها هي واجهزه هي
واجهزتها المسانده لها ثقه منا في سلامه
موقفنا القانوني
ولنتقاسم مع شعبنا ادوارهم البطوليه
في الصبر والثبات والدفا والدفاع عن كيان
دولته من الاختطاف تحيه والتقدير والنصر
لشعبنا ولقوته المسلحه وهم يقاتلون في
معركه الكرامه الوطنيه
وندعو
منسوب الدعم السريع المنحل
للانخراط مع اخوتهم في القوات المسلحه
وترك الالتزام تجاه قيادتهما الحاليه التي
ثبت انها تقودهم لمشروع شخصي واسري فقط
تقبل الله الشهداء
وشفت جرحى ورد المفقودين وواسل متضررين
والمتاثرين وما النصر الا صبر ساعه ينصره
الله فلا غالب لكم والله قالب على امره
احمد محمد هارون عن المعتقلين من قيادات
الانقاذ بسيم كوبر بتاريخ 25 ابريل
ايضا المشاهدين الكرام استمرنا معكم الى
احمد هارون القياده في نظام البشير السابق
وهو كان ضمن القيادات المعتقله في سجن
كوبر هو يعلن اذن المغادره الى مكان اكثر
امانا بعد تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه
والامنيه هناك ومغادره كل السجناء كما قال
حول الموضوع ايضا معنا هنا في الاستوديو
هشام سلمان الكاتب والبحث
السياسي السوداني استاذ هشام اهلا بك معنا
استمعت معنا الى ما قاله القيادي احمد
هارون هل يعني ان قيادات البشير قد فرت من
سجن كوبر
والله يعني ذلك الحقيقه ذا تطور
الدراماتيكي للمشهد يعني
واضافه عقده جديده للمشهد المعقد اصلا
احمد هارون
يتكلم عن
الوطن هو في مشروع الحضاري ارتكب مجازر في
حق الشعب السوداني
لما كان بيمثل المشروع الحضاري وهو من ضمن
المطلوبين للمحكمه نتحدث عن احمد هارون لو
سمحت لي اين هو عمر البشير عمر البشير كان
مسجون في كوبر اين هو الان كان في
المستشفى كان في المستشفى علي في المستشفى
السلاح الطبي يعني فيفترض انه مستشفى صلاح
الطبي ما تم اطلاق صراحه منه فهو بالنسبه
للصف الاول انا بفتكر متحفظ عليهم في مكان
امن اما بالنسبه لاحمد هارون ممكن يكون
طلع لانه المخاطبه دي تعني انه هو موجود
في السجن نعم
وبالتالي تطور جديد لكن احمد هارون هو
اصلا من هو احمد هارون الذي استمعنا اليه
قبل قليل القياده في نظام البشير قياده في
نظام البشير وهو خليني اعرف التعريف
المختضب
اللي هو هو متهم في المحكمه الجنائيه
وهو احد المطلوبين للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه نعم من ضمن المطلوبين الخمسه اللي
المفروض يسلمنا السودان للمحكمه الجنائيه
مطلوبين في غضايا ضد الانساني اللي هي
قضايا الاباده الجماعيه
ويعني
على المقاطعه لانه فعلا هذا خبر متفاعل
وانت وصفته بالحدث الدراماتيكي الذي يضيف
الان المزيد من التعقيد ذكرت انه نعرف ان
عمر البشير هو في المستشفى هو ليس مع هذه
القيادات التي خرجت الان القيادات الصف
الاول
بقياده احمد هارون غادروا الان هم قالوا
انهم موجودون في مكان امن لماذا هذا الحدث
تعتبره حدثا دراماتيكيا والله انا قبلت
سمعت لقاء او كان مع الناطق الرسمي باسم
القوات المسلحه وكان بيقول انه مدير السجن
قال انه هو اصبح
السجن غير امن بالنسبه للناس وما قادر
يوفر وجبات غذائيه وكذا على اساس انه كذا
قام فتحها وكان في وكده بالتالي يضطر انه
يطلق سراحه نعم
وانا بفتكر انه نعم خلي نقول نحن
انعكاسات الموضوع دشنا على المشهد
انا بفتكر انعكاساته وكبيره جدا وبتلغي
بظلال كبيره جدا على مسؤوليه الجيش في حفظ
الامر نعم وفي اللي هو الحفاظ على
يعني انت بكذا كانك انت ما
بتدق في في مسامير في نحش بدك تنشط الثوره
بشكل كامل
سعودي لهذه النقطه زملائي يشيلون لي باننا
كنا نشاهد على الشاشه صورا
يعني القياده احمد هارون مع الرئيس عمر
البشير
سابقا طبعا اثناء النظام السابق نحن نشاهد
كنا نشاهد هذه الصور
ها هي الصور اذا مره اخرى
طيب نتحدث ذكرت انه هذا الحدث سيعقد
المشهد خروج قيادات نظام البشير من السجن
كوبر اللافت في كلام احمد هارون استاذ
هشام ايضا اشادته بالقوات المسلحه ووصفه
لقوات الدعم السريع بالمنحلى بالقوه
المنحله ودعاها الى الانخراط او الانصهار
في الجيش السوداني ماذا يعني هذا هو اليوم
خلافاته كانت مع قائد الدعم السريع يعني
مع محمد حمدان لكن اصلا يعني هو اغرار ما
هو مغرر
هذا لا يعد اضافه الناس كلها بتقيس مع
المؤسسه المؤسسه العسكريه بحكم انها هي
قانونا هي
مكلفه بحمايه الوطن وبحمايه ارواح
المواطنين الى اخره فبالتالي ما اضاف شيء
الاضافه هو وما هي الجرائم التي ارتكبها
ضد الشعب السوداني احمد هارون
خليني نسال عن دي اول شيء بعدين نمشي
للنقطه الثانيه لانه هي قصتي انه انا اقول
والله القوات المسلحه
اقف معاها فده اغرار الاشياء حاصل يعني ما
فيه اضافه يعني لكن في اي اطارات ربما
طلبا
للحمايه ربما ممكن هو مش طلبا للحمايه هو
هو حاليا كل غيادات المؤتمر الوطني بتحاول
انها
تختطف المشهد على اساس انه تحصل على شرعيه
شرعيه الظهور مره ثانيه
للمشهد وللشعب السوداني هل يمكن ان يحصل
يمكن ان يعود النظام القديم يعود للمشهد
في ظل الاقتتال الحاصل في تقديره لا ابدا
مستحيل
النظام السابق تم لفظه من الشعب السوداني
نهائيا هو مشروع الذي يمثله نعم طيب اريد
ان اعود الى نقطه مهمه لانه الان القيادات
في نظام البشير كما استمعنا الى احمد
هارون في هذا التسجيل الصوتي مشاهدينا
معكم في هذا التطور الذي وصفه ضيفي
بالتطور الدراماتيكي في هذه الازمه
السودانيه اعلن خروجه من سجن كوبر برفقه
عدد من القياديين في النظام السابق
وانتقالهم الى مكان اكثر امانا عود الى
نقطه الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر البشير
هو كما ذكرت وعدد اخر من القياديين في
المؤتمر الوطني هم موجودون في مستشفى
السلاح الطبي السلاح الطبي العسكري
هل يقوم الجيش بتامينهم يعني هل يعني ممكن
هم معلوماتك انهم ما يزالون في المستشفى
ام جرى نقلهم
دورهم ايضا الى مكان اخر تم نقلهم لمكان
امن وانا بفتكر انهم هم مؤمنين
اخراجهم في اللحظه دي اما بتعني حاجه
واحده ماذا تعني تعني عوده النظام السابق
بواسطه القوات المسلحه ودي بتبقى يعني
فعلا هي ما اعتقد انه الكلام ده حاصل يعني
مش ما اعتقد انا اجزم بصحه انه مستحيل انه
يكون اخراج تم بواسطه القوات المسلحه طيب
ولكن او اي جهه نعم ولكن في هذه الحاله من
الطرف المستفيد من خروج قيادات النظام
السابق
وخروجهم من السجن الطرف المستفيد هو
المؤتمر الوطني اللي بحاول انه يعود مره
اخرى وبيحاول انه يستفيد من الازمه دي
يعني يحاول يجير الازمه دي لصالح اجندته
اللي هو العوده مره اخرى وهم قاعدين
بواسطه
يعني بواسطه كوادرهم الخارجيه الموجوده
خارج السجن كرتي والى اخره قاعدين شغالين
يعني بيحاولوا انه يرجعوا للمشهد ويحاولوا
يخطفوا الثمره بتاعت الخلافه اللي حصل ده
تحت الحرب اللي حصلت دي على اساس انه
يغيروها لصالح
المؤفره عن وضع البشير الصحي هل هو قادر
ان يعود مره اخرى للمشهد السياسي
والله هو صحيح ممكن يكون كويس لكن هل هو
سياسيه ممكن يعود للمشاه السياسي ولا لا
انا مفتكر انه عمر البشير كارت محروق يعني
لا يمكن ان يسوغ مره اخرى للشعب السوداني
له للمؤتمر الوطني مستحيل نعم اعاده انتاج
مره اخرى ظهور احمد هارون بهذا الشكل بهذا
التسجيل الصوتي
واعلنه انه يحترم القرارات القضاء وانه هم
خرجوا من السجن مضطرين كما استمعنا في
التسجيل الصوتي لانه المساجين خرجوا ولم
يعد هناك ظروف ملائمه وهم يمتثلون لامر
القضاء واشاد بدور المؤسسه العسكريه
هل يمكن ان يفهم من هذا الكلام ان ربما
احمد هارون ممكن ان يعود الى الواجهه ما
اعتقد هو افتكر انه المؤتمر الوطني كله هو
دي مرحله خطاه الزمن وتخطى الشعب السوداني
شعب السودان
شعب السوداني حاليا عنده ثوره والمؤمن بيع
عند اهدافه اللي بتنتهي بالتغيير اللي هو
السقف بتاعه
الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي وانتخابات حره
وتسلطه المدنيين واعاده عوده الجيش الى
سكناته
المثالي هذا ما كان يتمناه السودانيون
ولكن اليوم وفق المعطيات الحاليه لدينا
فصلان عسكريان يتقاتلان ولدينا الان نظام
سابق قيادته تخرج من السجن انا بسال سؤال
هم مهما تحاربوا وان شاء الله اللي مدى
عشر سنوات حيحكم وين حكومه الشعب السوداني
ما مقبولين لن يقبل السودانيون ان يحكم
نظام مره اخرى انا بقول دائما في مستحيلات
ثلاثه زي ما في
مستحيلات ثلاثين السودان ده ثاني لا يمكن
ان يحكم بواسطه المؤتمر الوطني او اي اي
واجهه
استاذ هشام تم التراجع عنها في السودان صح
ولا لا ما الذي يمنع دي مس يعني انا لا
اتبنى اي موقف الصراحه يعني حتى لا يعني
ولكن انا احاول ان يعني اتناول الموضوع من
كل الزوايا حتى نفهم ما يحصل يعني لانه
هكذا كما تفضلت انت وصفت خروج قيادات
النظام السابق من السجن لانه حدث
دراماتيكي يضيف يعني تعقيدا المشهد المعقد
لكن بقول انه دي مش دي مستحيلات انه
السودان لا يمكن يحكم يرجع مره تاني في
المشهد المؤتمر الوطني او احدى واجهاته لا
يمكن ان يحكم مره اخرى بواسطه العسكر
نهائيا يعني يحكموا عسكري مره ثانيه
السودان الشعب السوداني ما يقبل ويمكن
الناس شافت النتيجه حصلت بعد انقلاب 25
انه الشعب قبل ما يطلع البيان كانت في
الشارع كله
السودان لا يمكن ان يحكم بواسطه
الديكتاتوريه او بواسطه نظام شمولي مهما
كانت شمولي يمين يساري عسكري مدني لا يمكن
دي اصبحت مستحيلات عند الشعب السوداني
مهما كانت المحاولات اللي بتحاول تنتج اي
انظمه اخرى شموليه باي شكل كان عسكري ولا
مدني باي واجهه كانت غير استاذ هشام
الموضوع يعني يتحمل الكثير من النقاش
ساعود اليك ولكن مشاهدينا نعود طبعا
التسجيل الصوتي للقياده في نظام البشير
احمد هارون نستمع اليه مره اخرى ونعود
لنقاش هذا التطور الهام في الازمه
السودانيه هذه الليله نستمع الى احمد
هارون
بما في ذلك حدثنا لديها طلبا لرضا سياسيه
واخرى اقليميه ودوليه ثبت الان انها العدو
الاول للشعب السوداني
وللسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه
فهي من تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
ونفرغ تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك
السلطه ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف
وبشجاعه وبساله كالعدي بها دوما وندعو كل
جماهير الشعبنا
وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاف حولها
ومساندتها واستراح المبادره التي تسند
دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان جماهير
شعبنا الوفيه ضلنا كقيادات للثوره الانقاذ
الوطني
بمحبسنا بكوبرا
حتى تقاطع نيران المعرفه الدائره الان
لمده تسعه ايام
نتشارك وبقيه نزلاء السجن وسجانيه تلك
الظروف الامنيه الاستثنائيه
وانعدام مقومات الحياه من انقطاع تام
للمياه والكهرباء والطعام والرعايه الصحيه
حتى للجرحى من جراء تساقط النيران وسط قوه
السجون والنزلاء والتي توفى من جرائها
العديد منهم وجرح
ومنفجار الاوضاع داخل السجن بخروج كل
النزلاء يوم الاحد 23 ابريل 2023 من السجن
حتى خلى تماما من نزلائه وسيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره
من قاده وضباه وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه
المتبقيه من قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر
خارج السي
تحت حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه على امل ان تتحصل سلطات السجون على
امر القضاء بالافراج عنا حسب افادتها خلال
ذلك اليوم لنواجه مع جماهير شعبنا لا تزور
فيه وتحدياته والقيام معه بذات الواجبات
الوطنيه فلم تعد هناك سيون قائمه ولا مقار
لمباشره اجهزه ووكالات انفاذ القانون
لمهامها
وهكذا في الانقياده ضريبتها والتزاماتها
ونفخر ونحمد الله كثيرا على تشربنا تماما
لقيم موروثات شعبنا التي يعبر عنها بالمثل
السمعه ولا طوله العمر واذا عدم صدور
الامر القضائي المستحق قانونا لاسباب غير
قانونيه
عنها لاحقا وفي ظل تسارع وتتابع الاحداث
وازدياد حته الاشتباكات وتعاظم النذر
والمخاطر من حولنا وفي ظل انشغال السلطات
الاخرى بمهامها في اداره المعركه الوطنيه
الان القائمه فقد اتخذنا قرارا الخاص بنا
بان نتحمل المسؤوليتنا في حمايه انفسنا
بانفسنا وجاهزون للوصول امام السلطه
القضائيه متى ما تمكنت من القيام بمهامها
هي واجهزه هي واجهزتها المسانده لها ثقه
منا في سلامه موقفنا القانوني
ولنتقاسم مع شعبنا ادوارهم بطوليه
في الصبر والثبات والدفاع عن كيان دولته
من الاختطاف تحيه والتقدير والنصر لشعبنا
ولقوته المسلحه وهم يقاتلون في معركه
الكرامه الوطنيه
وندعو
منسوب الدعم السريع المنحل
للانخراط مع اخوتهم في القوات المسلحه
وترك الالتزام تجاه قيادتهما الحاليه التي
ثبت انها تقودهم لمشروع شخصي واسري فقط
تقبل الله الشهداء
وشاف الجرحى ورد المفقودين وواسل متضررين
والمتاثرين وما مصر الا صبر ساعه ينصره
الله فلا غالب لكم والله قالب على امره
احمد محمد هارون عن المعتقلين من قيادات
الانقاذ بسيم كوبر بتاريخ 25 ابريل
هذا مشاهدي معكم مره اخرى لهذا التسجيل
الصوتي لاحمد هارون القيادي في نظام
البشير بعد مغادره قيادات النظام السوداني
السابق الذي اطيح به في ثوره شعبيه
مغادرتهم للسجن كوبر كما ذكرنا كما
استمعنا اليه وهو يقول ان هناك بسبب
انعدام الامن هناك في سجن كوبر فوا في
اولى ردود الفعل لدينا الان اول تصريح بعد
هذا البيان لقيادات نظام البشير القيادي
في قوى الحريه والتغيير ياسر عرمان يعتبر
ان بيان قيادات البشير بعد مغادرتهم السجن
هو دعوه لتوسيع نطاق الحرب استاذ هشام
سلمان انت كنت وصفت هذا البيان بانه حدث
دراماتيكي الان ياسر عرمانيا يعتبرها دعوه
لتوسيع نطاق الحرب كيف سيتسع نطاق الحرب
بخروج قيادات نظام البشير من السجن
هو اصلا صناعه المشهد ده بتدل على انه
فعلا هو مشهد مش توسيع نطاق الحظ ولتصبح
حرب شامله انا بفتكر انه بين من ومن
الحقيقه النظام السابق ده هو حارب الشعب
السوداني كله النظام السابق اذا كان احمد
هارون نساني احنا ما نسينا جيبوا وكان
بيستكثر بيقول الطلقه بسبعه جنيه ما تضربه
دي مخاطباته يتخاطب بالقانون الثوره عملته
بالقانون لانه الشعب السوداني شعب في
ثورته كان الافق بتاعه انه يعمل دوله
قانون لانه هذا هو احمد هارون نعم نعم هم
في في
حكمهم غاب القانون نهائيا
وقتل الناس بدون بدون وجه حق في السجون
وفي بيوت الاشباح والتعذيب والقتل والقتل
خالد خارج نطاق القانون
الجرائم ضد الانسانيه اللي هي الانتهاكات
اللي حصلت في دارفور وهو من المطلوبين
للمحكمه الجنائيه في قضايا ضد الانسانيه
يعني نعم نعم طيب طبعا
ولكن هل يمكن بالفعل ان يكون هذا هذا
السيناريو واردا استاذ هشام ان يكون
عوده للنظام السابق او على الاقل يعني ليس
بشكل يعني بعمر البشير ربما بشكل او باخر
ان يعود النظام السابق لانه ممكن ان يقول
انظروا طيب نظام ديكتاتوري او الفوضى ماذا
تخ ماذا تختارون
والحقيقه
ما هكذا تورد
انا بفتكر انه
عوده النظام السابق للحكومه مره اخرى دي
من المستحيلات في السودان لانه نظام حكم
30 سنه لم يرى السودان فيه الا كل شيء سيء
وحتى النتائج التي تحصل والحرب اعذرني
ارجو ان تبقى معي فقط نذهب الان الى
مراسلنا وهو موجود الان وهذه الصور
المباشره اذا من صلاه القدوم في ميناء جده
الاسلامي حيث يتم استقبال رعايه من
الجنسيه الهنديه قادمين من ميناء
بورتسودان عبر سفينه هنديه حربيه يبلغ عدد
الذين تم اجلائهم اذا كما نشاهد هنا العدد
هو
293 شخصا نشاهد الان هم بداوا في الوصول
الى مطار او الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وقد
قامت السعوديه بتامين هذا الممر المائي
وتقديم الدعم والخدمه اللوجستيه حتى وصول
السفينه الى جده بامان نحن نتابع هذه
الصور ومن هناك من ميناء جده مع ان
مراسلنا هاني الصفيان هاني المزيد من
التفاصيل حول عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
التي ترعاها السعوديه من السودان
نعم اهلا بك صهيب واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا مازلنا نواكب عمليه وصول
اجلام الرعايه من جنسيه متعدده والذين
يصلون الى السعوديه عبر اما قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه او كذلك قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه او ايضا هنا في ميناء جده
الاسلامي ولكن نتحدث اليوم عن وصول اول
رحله التجاريه او عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي
وهي السادسه بالنسبه للسفن التي وصلت
السعوديه طبعا هذه الرحله تحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن
من رعايه
الجنسيه الهنديه والتي قدمت او الذين
قدموا عبر السفينه حربيه
هنديه قدمت من بورتو السودان الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي السعوديه طبعا كانت في
تصريحاتها والبياناتها السابقه انها هي
هيئه ايضا ممرات مائيه ليب عدد من السفن
التي ترغب بنقل رعاياها الى مدينه جده
وبعد ذلك يتم استضافتهم وكذلك نقلهم عبر
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الجوي عبر الرحلات
الطيران طبعا هذه اللحظات الاولى من وصول
هذا العدد من الجنسيه الهنديه وعددهم
من المواطنين الهنديين والان تقوم ايضا
الجهات المعنيه الاخرى من وزاره الصحه
وكذلك نشاهد في الكاميرا الاخرى التي
ترصدها العربيه من خلال عمليات الكونترات
والمنصات التي وفرتها الجوازات السعوديه
حتى يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم في اقصى سرعه
طبعا في مثل هذه الحالات الان وفي عمليات
الاجراء او الاجراء العمليات الانسانيه
يتم عمليه اعطاهم بعض اللقاحات وكذلك
اجراء بعض الفحوصات الطبيه لا هو بعد ذلك
يتوجهون مباشره الى منصات الجائى والمنصات
الخاصه بنهاء اجراءاتهم وبعد ذلك يتم
نقلهم عبر الحافلات المخصصه الى مقرات
اقامتهم وبعد ذلك كيف سيتم عمليه ترتيب
مغادرتهم للسعوديه هاني
طبعا هناك الملحق السفاره الهنديه هي
موجوده والمندوب ايضا موجود وكان السفير
الهندي هنا موجود ايضا وحاضر في استقبال
ابناء جريدتي وكذلك يتم ايضا نقلهم الى
مقرات اقامتهم وايضا الى الفنادق المخصصه
لهم حيث يتم استعداد
الاستعداد اللازم بالنسبه لهم ويتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم بعد ذلك ومغادرتهم بشكل نهائي
الى بلدانهم طبعا هذه كما اوضحت ان هذه
الدفعه الاولى هناك ايضا دفعات سوف تليها
خلال الساعات القادمه ولكن من جنسيات
متعدده وعبر سفن السعوديه نعم صهيب شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الصوره الحيه وصول وفد
من
الجاليه الهنديه الذين تم اجلائهم من
بورتسودان عبر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى ميناء جده شكرا جزيلا لك هاني حتى
الان ونع مشاهدينا الى الخبر الرئيس في
هذه الساعه واعلان قيادات من نظام البشير
مغادرتها لسجن كوبر في تسجيل صوتي لاحمد
هارون القيادي في نظام البشير استاذ هشام
اعود اليك تناولنا كل السيناريوهات
ودلالات وتبعات ربما سيحصل ياسر عرمان
اعتبر ان هذا خروج قياده النظام البشير
يوسع من نطاق هذه الحرب ولكن يعني احمد
هارون قال انهم جاهزون لتسليم انفسهم
للسلطات القضائيه عندما تطلب ذلك هل يمكن
ان يكون هذا واردا ان لا نحمل الامور اكثر
مما تحتمل الرجل يقول نحن فقدنا الامان في
السجن لانه الاوضاع الامنيه منفلته هربوا
الى مكان امن وعندما يطلبهم القضاء
السوداني ويتم اعاده الامن سيعودون الى
سجنهم
مصيرهم في ويحاسب على من قتلوا ومن سحلوا
ومن ومن ومن ومن على جرائمهم والمتعدده
انا بفتكر
يعني
حاليا
محاوله انتاج المؤتمر الوطني مره قديم او
بشكل جديد مره اخرى كانما انت بتصدر شهاده
ميلاد لانسان ميت
بالضبط
انت لا تعتقد بالفعل انه المساله انه
فقدان الامان في السجون وبانهم يخرجون
وربما سيعودون الى السجن عندما تهدا
الامور حتى ولو خرجوا ما بيمثلوا شيء
اصبحوا اصبحوا ذيل انا ما بقول لك
وبالنسبه اليوم كحزب وكمشروع حتى المشروع
الحضاري نفسه اللي هم
من خلاله سحلوا وقتلوا عذبوا وارتكبوا كل
الجرائم والموبقات بل ونهبوا سرقوا والى
اخره
هذا المشروع انا بفتكر ادى الى وفاه هذه
الحركه والحزم ده قصتي تصدر لها شهاده
ميلاد وشهاده ميلاد لشخص ميت يعني
تزوير في اوراق رسميه نعم طيب ولكن الان
ما المتوقع كذلك على صعيد الاقتتال الان
عندما حسب المعلومات كما تفضلت الرئيس
السابق عمر البشير ما يزال في المستشفى
ما المنتظر الان من المؤتمر الوطني او
قيادات
النظام السابق النظام السابق خارج المشهد
يعني هو حاليا اي لعبه نحن بنعاني كل
المعاناه وكل الافرازات الموجوده دي هي
نتائج لاعمالهم يعني الدعم السريع من الذي
خلق الدعم السريع هو عمر البشير عملوا
لحمايته حتى بقول حمايتي لحميتي ولانه
حمايتي وخلقوا وشرعنوا وعمل له قانون
وجاؤوا بعد ذلك حتى شرعوا زياده يعني
وسلحوا الى اخره
لكن اليوم احمد هارون وصفه بالقوه المنحله
وعليكم العوده الى الجيش بس احمد هارون
باي صفه بيتكلم انت مجرم هارب حاليا انت
كنت مجرم مسجون انت تعتبر الان القيادات
هذه يعني هارون من السجن هاربون انت مهارب
من السجن انت اصلا عليك قضايا ومفروض
تحاكم وباللي انت عليك قضايا دوليه يعني
انت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه طالباك في
قضايا ضد الانسانيه قضايا بتاعه اباده
جماعيه يعني
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا اذا الاستاذ هشام سلمان
الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني اذن
مشاهدينا مصادر العربيه تقول ان عوض الجاز
وابراهيم السنوسي ضمن قيادات نظام البشير
التي غادرت سجن كوبر وكذلك نافع لنافع
عليه عثمان طه ضمن قياده نظام البشير التي
غادرت سجن كوبر كذلك المشاهدين هذا حدث
لافت في هذه
الازمه السودانيه المزيد في التغطيه
المستمره الساعه المواليه معك طاهر بركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات